this episode was proudly made possible
by Subaru
[Music]
so there's a term I really like called
the adrenaline half and that's this idea
that we have co-opted biological systems
in this case alarm systems and then used
them towards cultural lens so for
example we get an adrenaline rush the
response to a perceived danger and has
to decide whether to fight neutralized
or flight and run away to survive
it's a biological alarm system inducing
anxiety and fear so that we get out of
the dangerous situation right but the
fact that is modern cultural beings now
that inhabit lash is an imagination
we've created systems with twerkin
technologies that co-op these biological
alarm systems and place them in safe
contexts so that we can experience our
bio chemical signature our the surging
multiplicity of emotions to which we are
privy to in a safe setting for example
watching a scary movie going on a
rollercoaster ride
skydiving your brain is telling you
danger the adrenaline rush is the one of
impending doom and
yet the fact that you know you're in a
safe space allows you on a meta level to
be aware that you're not gonna die and
therefore enjoy the Wonder and amazement
and the heart of the bearable ecstasy of
direct energy exploding through nerve
and the existing that they we're II
would say so think about that the next
time you sty dive or you add a scary
movie you were like all right let me
experience the full spectrum of human
emotion in a safe setting it's
unbelievable and external impact and
it's what makes us such creative beings
[Music]
be sure to check out second chance
Subaru at revision3.com Subaru